vingt ans plus tard une journée
identique vue du ciel mais des
circonstances plus heureuse
à 85 ans l'américaine shirley paul jones
revient à gander pour une 30e visite à
tout
juste
le 11 septembre 2001 est probablement la
meilleure chose qui lui soit arrivée
ce jour là la femme était à bord du vol
delta 15 voyageant de francfort à
atlanta elle faisait partie des six
mille neuf cents passagers coincés dans
les 38 avions qui avaient été détournés
vers cannes de l'espace aérien américain
est enfermé game d'un compte moins de
10000 habitants ces populations a
subitement presque doublé
au même moment bel ou peu travaillé à
son imprimerie
il était aussi maire de lewis porte une
petite ville voisine de gelder qui a
accueilli 7 170 passagers en moins de 24
heures la communauté s'immobiliser pour
les loger les nourrir et les réconforter
bill et temaru peur ont ouvert les
portes de leur maison à trois femmes
dont charles ebooks jones
thomas et bill roper sont devenus sa
deuxième famille
sur les bourses chose a changé la vie du
couple et fluence est celle de centaines
de jeunes du coin en guise d'héritage et
de remerciement elle a mis sur pied une
bourse d'études pour contrer le
décrochage scolaire un problème dans la
région
du centre
never jusqu'ici plus d'un million $ a
été amassé 3 141 jeunes en ont bénéficié
vingt ans plus tard elle débarque au
terminal 2 kender comme en septembre
2001 sans vêtement de rechange sa valise
n'a pas franchi toutes les escales cet
agent de sécurité du promet de lui
apporter en main propre à lewis porte
dès que possible s'il ya une chose qui
n'a pas changé en 20 ans ici c'est bien
la générosité des citoyens ici mode
montambault radio-canada kendo